do you have to uphold the code like
you're doing these parts with all these
gang members they have their own code do
they look at you like a square and they
go okay you don't have to operate like
this or because you're operating with
them
you have to uphold it I think there's a
lot that's expected of me in terms of
just not you know obviously if I were to
talk to a cop about something that was
said on my podcast like but but can you
hang with bloods oh yeah so even the
dudes that you you roll with that are
[ __ ] or cool they don't expect any of
that kind of [ __ ] okay no and even most
of the Crips in La don't have problems
with the blood specific it's like set
per set yeah it's like they'll have a
problem with this neighborhood in this
neighborhood and a bunch of [ __ ]
neighborhoods Etc it's not like Crips
versus Bloods at all yeah but um yeah no
like I mean but okay this is one thing a
lot of people think that I'm having
conversations off camera with rappers
about Street [ __ ] that they would never
say on camera which I I also consider
that kind of part of the code that when
I I know that Fredo bang an NBA young
boy for instance like people around them
have
killed each other basically they're like
both parts of opposing gangs there's all
kinds of murders tied to the beef
between them and stuff I'm very close
with Fredo bang had a lot of long
in-depth conversations with him never
has it crossed my mind to be like okay
who killed young boy's cousin who who
killed this guy like an awesome and that
kind of [ __ ] and I don't think they
would tell me if I asked but I don't I
don't ask that kind of stuff because
it's like why do I need to know that you
know and yeah me as a rap fan I would
like to know but I don't I don't cross
that line so I don't feel like even if
there was a cop in my face trying to get
me to tell him everything I know
incriminating about rappers I can't
really think of almost anything that I
know that isn't already out there that
like you know it's like just I don't
really wade into like wanting to know
that kind of stuff that's crazy has an
interview ever been used in a deposition
not mine I heard about a Nick Cannon
interview being used against Arab I
believe who's doing like 50 years right
now he had a Philly uh yeah we
interviewed him once on idiots yeah oh
wow I think I think we had AR album
idiots once Arab uh I don't want to call
him an idiot but if you go watch the
videos of him snitching on himself it is
mind-blowing hopefully there's never
another person who snitches on
themselves like that in interviews
because he's really in some of these old
interviews being like I've robbed so and
so for these bricks and I [ __ ] like
ordered this and that and it's like just
search Arab snitching it's like some of
the most mind-blowing she'll ever see on
YouTube okay now that they're using the
lyrics yeah to get these dudes in court
crazy how much does the music change one
and two will we ever see
real street rappers again
yeah I mean I think they'll always find
a way around it because a lot a lot of
it's like really coded language like
when I look at some of the Instagram
stories or whatever from these dudes in
the Bronx or like the craziest drill
rappers ever yeah to a normal person you
would not read this and think that this
was like basically them talking about
murder yeah but they use like a lot of
really weird slang and [ __ ] that it
would be very and that's not just for
the courts that's because you know if
you were to write like I so-and-so
killed your brother on your Instagram
story it would probably get taken down
right right but if you write like
something more coded and you slang and
[ __ ] like that like so a lot of times
I'm reading this [ __ ] and I have to read
over like two or three times before I'm
like Ah that's what they're getting at
or even like we've put out videos where
there was K flock who's currently facing
a murder or whatever like he uh that he
had a vlog that we did and on one of it
one of the dudes around him is saying
hey we smoking rah-rah and then I find
out that Rara is this like 16 year old
kid in the Bronx who got murdered oh I
got the weed when you said that well
yeah but they call their they say that
they put the Dead Ops in a blunt right
so at this time when I heard that I
didn't know that they were talking about
it and I mean you know I don't really
want to like celebrate that I probably
would have believed his name if I've
been able to because that [ __ ] is just
like little but you have no idea well I
didn't know at that time you're just
like agreeing with him on video you're
like yeah we are and you're like oh no
yeah things out if you think you'll get
the person in trouble because I know
like uh Vlad used to take slack for that
sometimes if it seems over the line or
we'll cut it out if it's like like I
just don't want my platform to be used
for like actually aggravating Gang
Beasts if a rapper wants to sit there
and say I have a problem with this
rapper and here's why that's that's one
thing if a rapper is going to sit there
and say [ __ ] blank and there's all these
words for different gangs that like you
know you're not really even supposed to
say or whatever I mean the obvious ones
is that Crips called blood swabs and
blood's called Crips crabs right and so
like you know I would never let somebody
say that kind of [ __ ] on the podcast
because it's just instigating it's like
almost guaranteed to cause Bloodshed you
know so it's like there's stuff like
that if you want to say I don't like
this rapper I don't like this guy over
here whatever that's one thing but when
they're throwing this like hole because
that's like the kind of thing that's
just gonna aggravate so much tension
people start pulling up to the studio
you guys are potentially in danger yeah
are you not more worried about it I'm
more I don't think they're gonna think
about it like but I don't want to be a
part of it
to me yeah I mean obviously but like I
could see somebody doing something dumb
for clout like you see people doing dumb
[ __ ] for cloud all the time yeah you
know and it's like I don't understand
how you're just so calm about everything
I want to know what your life like
no besides argue just like in life like
what it like how do you not do you get
anxious are you yeah I mean every time
he leaves for work like little scenarios
go through my head and when it comes
home I'm like okay everything's fine
everything's fine everything's okay and
especially after the like you know it
was a fake gun the incident on Melrose
but like that was definitely scary
[Music]
foreign
[Music]